if you were living in an apartment full
of murderers and horrifying monsters
what would you do you'll be forced to
watch everyone you know die in your
building and there's no way to escape
I'm going to break down the mistakes
made what you should do and how to beat
the spirit bugs in Oregon signs of
Vermilion this girl has no idea that she
is about to be brutally murdered Rin
here is your average shy University girl
living in a city full of murderers and
violence she gets off of the train and
heads to her new apartment but realizes
that it looks nothing like the ad
wanting to say something to the
apartment manager she stands at the
office door but is too scared to cause
any trouble she heads inside through the
entrance of this dark empty building but
comes across the man staring at a bug on
the ground the bug suddenly dies and
worms start ripping out of its corpse
horrified she quickly runs inside as the
man creepily watches her walking away
taking the elevator the lights begin
flickering as the doors open up she
walks out but notices something
terrifying right next to her and sees a
dark shadow of an elderly woman talking
to herself in the corner scratching and
scratching her skin and covered in blood
saying the bugs got in the bugs got in
Wren is shocked and runs straight into
her apartment later she takes her
medicine and climbs into bed scared for
her life as she hears strange sounds
coming from her build she turns on the
news and sees that another person has
just been murdered in her area with this
victim found bleeding from the neck but
she doesn't realize that after five more
murders it will be her turn to die
great we're now stuck in a contract that
we don't have the balls to get out of
Rin here not visiting the apartment
before signing the contract was a rookie
move to say the least and is on par with
what is the reality of the real estate
market when it comes to falsely
advertising homes by making them look
really nice and you want to live in them
when in reality of their total dumps and
these days with all the latest tech
tactics to advertise homes includes
using the latest and greatest Tech to
outright distort or even deceive buyers
into making the advertised home even if
it's really trash in real life look
amazing in photos and this makes sense
if we think about where she is a dingy
and a downright dangerous part of town
which for a college-aged girl is a
little concerning I would say and this
probably means that she can't even trust
her closest neighbor because they're all
probably nuts and her not checking out
the apartment in advance makes me think
that she's quite the most gullible thing
here and worrying about one serial
killer around her neighborhood should be
the least of her worries since if she's
not careful literally anywhere she goes
in this area will make her a walking
Target at this point I would assess the
area and figure out her situation more
thoroughly and look into the people
living in her area especially her
neighbors and their circumstances and
also employment situation because
poverty breeds crime and the last thing
that Rin needs right now is to find out
that she's living next to groups of
psychos who will not come to her Aid in
an emergency but might even Rob her or
even worse the next day Ren heads back
home after her University class and
Crosses this bridge heading down these
steps she suddenly hallucinates her
death happening right in front of her
and she collapses in Chuck running to
this playground to catch her breath she
takes her medicine and tries to calm
down suddenly she sees a strange
black-haired girl begin dancing right in
front of her noticing her stare the
strange girl walks up to Rin and
introduces herself as nasua worried
about the recent murders around the area
Rin tells her that they have to head
home soon before it gets dark but that's
when nasua reveals that the killings in
this area were done by a man known
online as the Savior and that this
person purifies lost souls and tells Rin
that this mysterious killer was a part
of a secret society that stopped bad
curses from happening but eventually he
lost his mind and now no one is safe and
now Rin thinks that this girl is batshit
crazy and leaves but she has no idea
that this woman has already costed her
her life heading back to her apartment
Rin suddenly sees the horrifying corpse
of an old woman as EMTs drag her out on
a stretcher out of the building passing
by her body Wren sees the old woman's
hand fall down just as a horrifying bug
explodes from her arm and slithers away
right in front of wren's eyes shocked
she begs to speak with the doctors but
they leave her before she can say
anything suddenly she notices the same
man again from yesterday sitting near
her creeping her out and she heads back
inside the next morning Rin desperately
tries to search for more information
about the bug she saw last night and
begins to think that there is a
connection between the bugs that she
keeps seeing the elderly woman and the
recent murders that have begun happening
just as the police find another dead
victim nearby making that one down and
four more to go and death is just
getting started later at her University
Rin looks through the library and comes
across a special book grabbing it she
suddenly sees horrifying insects spray
out from the bookcase realizing she's
tripping balls Rin goes to pick up the
book and notices a drawing it's the same
bug from last night suddenly this
glasses guy walks over and notices the
title of her book Rin tries to walk away
but that's when he suspects that she can
see the bugs too curious he asks to talk
to her and she tells him that she thinks
that all of these weird events that
she's begun to see are just because of
her psych meds but glasses guy thinks
there is something deeper going on and
mentions that long ago people used to
believe in the concept of spear Spirit
bugs which were said to live within
people and traveled between Dimensions
to judge the worth of souls but that's
when he reveals something horrifying and
tells Rin that if she has begun to see
Spirit bugs then that means that it
won't be long until she ends up dead he
hands her a drawing and tells her to
watch out for this bug specifically as
the person who drew this red bug died as
well and tells her that if she's not
careful her turn to die will come sooner
than she thinks he hands her his
business card but Ren begins to sweat
and leaves him to head back home before
the conversation can even finish not
even realizing that that was her biggest
mistake okay this is huge because even
though this glasses guy might look like
he's got a little bit of a strange
glasses guy energy about him what he's
basically saying is that Rin here is
royally screwed and will likely soon die
if she doesn't do something about it
because up until this point she's seen
countless bugs of All Sorts the moment
she moved into her apartment however
there is one variable here that makes me
question if what Rin is seeing is truly
real or not because Rin here thinks that
what she's been seeing recently has been
due to her psych medication which
judging from the context of that may
mean that Rin suffers from some sort of
psychosis which is a condition that
makes people lose contact with reality
believing certain delusions that may not
be actually real and judging from how
Rin is acting this may mean that she is
in the early stages of developing
psychosis also known as attenuated
psychosis syndrome where people suffer
only mild delusions and when the
condition hasn't fully developed yet
this means that Rin has two factors to
consider here folks one from her
instability in the brain two to what
this creepy glasses guy is telling us
and judging from the types of bugs Rin
has seen it likely won't be long before
she comes across that red Spirit bug
that he is talking about this means that
if I were in I would not leave glasses
guy's sight until we understand what
we're up against and I'd also study up
on learning the mythology of the Spirit
Box and I'd find anyone else who might
know more about this but also in rin's
emotional state she forgot to note one
very important detail that glasses guy
told her about and that was that he has
seen the spirit bugs too ding ding ding
ding she should have picked up on that
one which means according to the lore
it's only a matter of time until he's
dead too this means that Ren might have
had a better chance if she stuck by his
side since he knows what she's going
through and Rin may be able to use
glasses guy as a you guessed it Shield
of meat if she needs to because one
thing's for sure staying in a group is
better than going at this solo so
finding people in her same situation
will be one method to ensure her
survival or at the very least better her
chances at making it out of this alive
terrified Wren runs back home and
immediately inspects glasses guys
business card but she notices something
strange behind her turning around she
sees the lights in the distance begin to
Flicker and her heart begins to race
suspicious she turns around and
continues to walk when she hears the
footsteps of someone else behind her and
she hears the horrifying sound of an
electric saw turning on Rin starts
running reaching the second floor as
fast as she can and the killer begins
catching up to her seeing this random
Empty Apartment she quickly enters it
and locks the door behind her thinking
the worst is over she tries to catch her
breath but she suddenly Hears A violent
banging on the door the killer tries to
get in as Wren watches and horror but
suddenly all the noise stops not knowing
whose apartment she's in predictably she
begins to look around hearing something
through this doorway she decides to
cautiously check it out but suddenly
blacks out later Rin wakes up back in
her apartment with no memory of how she
got there she steps out of her balcony
to catch her breath but notices nasua
wanting to discuss what just happened
Rin tries to follow the black-haired
girl heading down into the second
building but then she suddenly starts to
have a painful attack blurring her
vision and she blacks out again later
she wakes up outside of her apartment
and she he's the same man from the
beginning hipster guy he tells her he
rescued her and that he is an observer
of insects and plans to master their
rituals confused is all hell Rin tries
to take some of her meds but discovers
that hipster guy throughout her pills he
tells her that she shouldn't be taking
that medicine and this pisses Rin off
feeling bad the man takes off his
hipster necklace and hands it to Rin
telling her that this will protect her
and that she should not go to that part
of her building ever again later in her
room Rin begins to research about the
horrifying murders that keep happening
in her area and discovers that all the
victims died of blood loss but had their
necks broken at a right angle which
means that the killer broke their neck
after they were already dead researching
further Rin discovers an old article
that reveals that the recent murdered
bodies matched the description of a
mysterious disease that struck this area
40 years ago Ren is horrified and
quickly heads down to her library to
find more local information about the
disease discovering that 40 years ago
the there was a disease in this area
called the tilting sickness which causes
the patience of this disease to suffer
mutations of their neck and Spine and
that they all came into contact with the
same red bug Rin saw earlier however the
true cause of the incident was never
discovered okay this is ludicrous
because right now Rin has just
discovered a huge secret and this likely
explains why her student apartment was
within her affordable price range and
explains the false advertising that
lured her into renting it to begin with
what creepo glasses guy here basically
told rent is that the patients in those
experiments all those years ago suffered
mutations of the cervical vertebrae
which consists of the first seven
vertebrae or backbones in your spine and
this could explain how and why the
killer chose to break the victim's necks
as a sort of homage to what happened all
those years ago however it's not clear
to what degree the murderer broke the
victim's neck however there is a chance
that these victims aren't entirely as
innocent as they seem as mentioned from
nasua she called the killer the Savior
which means this person could be killing
as a means to an end or to put a stop to
something that he considers to be evil
within this area and these victims
having their necks broken in the exact
same way as the lap experiments 40 years
ago could mean there's more going on
behind how these victims are dying and
if they are in any way connected to the
mutated Lab Rats who also have spine
mutations and this means that the killer
within this area may not be the only
thing that Rin needs to keep a close eye
on because all of this is too much of a
coincidence back in her apartment block
hipster guy investigates the apartment
that Ren went into earlier and he tries
to look for Clues as to what really
happened entering this dark room he
suddenly notices something sinister fly
past him just as this terrifying
creature appears from above his head and
brutally kills him devouring his
lifeless corpse and swallowing him up
completely that's two down and three
more to go meanwhile walking back home
from the library Rin tries to call
glasses guy for more answers but he
doesn't pick up just as a horrifying
black ghost briefly appears in front of
her and she then thinks that it's her
friend from earlier Nashua Rin watches
her dance and begins to think that
everything is going to be okay but
that's when she notices that something
is off about her and she heads back home
and she has no idea that she's just seen
something horrifying later in the shower
Rin starts dancing exactly like nasua
trying to remember what she saw and
that's when it hits her nasua had a tilt
in her neck she now has the tilting
sickness horrified she runs to go find
Nasa and save her before it's too late
and she begins to hallucinate her friend
covered in red bugs wrenth and sees
nasuo in the distance and chases her
down into her apartment block and she
enters this dark area suddenly she comes
across the same killer from earlier and
nasua who has now turned into a
horrifying creature and both of these
killers suddenly charge at Rin from both
directions all of a sudden blonde stud
shows up out of nowhere and decapitates
rin's friend right in front of her eyes
seeing NASA dead Rin tries to attack
blonde stud and anchor and he tries to
tell her that nasua had turned into what
is known as a dead soul soldier spirits
from another realm that invade the body
of someone about to die when their
Spirit bug leaves their body and once
the dead soldier invades a corpse well
that corpse becomes an Unstoppable
killing machine blonde stud tells Ren
that someone is creating these dead Soul
soldiers and that it is up to him to
stop them he tells Ren to get out of
town as soon as possible and that he'll
stop all of this evil from happening and
save the world and look badass doing it
suddenly a car on the highway flies off
of the road and smashes through the
building window and brutally kills
blonde stutt and destroys Humanity's
greatest hope all the while his Wren
tries to figure out what the hell just
happened and that's three down and two
more to go okay this is the most crazy
[ __ ] that I've ever seen happen in the
span of five minutes in a while because
the badass blind stud dude looked more
silly dying than a pig wearing lipstick
which brings me up to my point the type
of evil that Rin is facing is more than
just Evil Soul possessed zombies and not
to mention masked Killers with blades
trying to kill her as noted earlier
Spirit bugs are apparently within all
human beings essentially just like our
souls but the absence of a spirit bug
within a body means that the human in
question will basically have an empty
room sign on him and it means that their
body could be possessed by one of these
dead Soul soldiers since the mythology
of spared bugs is that they all live
within us unless someone reports seeing
bugs which therefore would be an
indication that they will die soon
unless that happens there is just no way
for us to know who else is at risk of
having their spare bug leave their body
and this likely is what happened to the
same person who just drove his car
through the window and killed Humanity's
greatest hope badass blind stud and
without his greatness it's doubtful that
Rin Will Survive it all she's toast but
woodrin could do at this point instead
of being a useless passive protagonist
she could choose to actively find more
people like glasses guy essentially
shamans or mystical experts familiar
with dealing with the concept of spirit
bugs and everything surrounded that
whole topic rather than simply trying to
do her own research and save the day all
by herself just like every main
character tries to do in a horror film
and remember she's just a university
student basically still a kid and
science tells us that kids are stupid
which means that she'd be better off
seeking out direct help rather than
trying to solo this level like some
cocky Noob don't do that don't be a noob
horrified Rin gets the hell out of there
but suddenly gets visions of nashua's
spirit cry and she tries to chase her
spirit down and catches up to her in
this apartment Wren hugs her and thinks
that everything will be okay but that's
when nasua suddenly pushes her down into
this dark hole waking up she realizes in
horror at where she is and sees a huge
pile of corpses right beneath her feet
suddenly she hears the screams of the
corpses under her and she tries to run
away coming across this iron door
however she notices thousands of red
bugs right above her head and freaks the
hell out just as she notices and exit to
escape room not being able to reach it
she begins piling corpses one by one
near the exit until she finally has
enough corpses to make a human ladder
climbing out through this vent she lands
in this Sinister empty room and
discovers a film of the experiments from
40 years ago about the horrifying
diseases discovering that the creation
of the Dead Soul soldiers was done on
purpose not realizing that one of these
monsters is about to come back and try
to kill her Rin stares at this projector
in horror just as this terrifying
monster drops and tries to attack her
forcing her to crawl for her sweet life
climbing under these tables the monster
starts to catch up to Rin as she reaches
this wall but suddenly it disappears
just then her hands get tied down by
this monster and she sees it appear
right above her staring at death in the
face she prepares to die right here but
suddenly hipster guy's necklace protects
her for a split second and Rin takes
this chance and she runs towards this
lift just as she sees a moth fly past
her the same one from earlier and
realizes that it's hipster guy's Spirit
The Moth flies into the monster's mouth
killing it in a horrifying explosion as
Rin barely manages to escape the
explosion causes the lift to fall as it
hits the bottom floor getting out she
finds countless drawings all over the
floor of the red moth and she heads
through this tunnel and she then finds
this fresh corpse of glasses guy
floating right in front of her that's
four down with one more to go horrified
Rin begins to panic but suddenly sees a
knife plunging straight towards her
chest by this psycho chick causing her
to pass out what this is insane because
at this point it's pretty clear that
science is not gonna help us out on this
one because even from the get-go it
makes no sense why Rin decided to remain
as complacent as she was when it was
obvious based on her area of living that
she was gonna run into some trouble to
begin with also Rin not noticing the
psycho lady behind her seems unlikely as
due to a Rain experience with the
monster just now that Rush of adrenaline
she likely felt during that encounter
would have still been coursing through
her body meaning that Rin would have
continued to feel the effects of
increased alertness improved Vision
hearing and other senses because of this
even if she wasn't feeling a biophysical
response already Common Sense would have
dictated that she was in a dangerous
area she doesn't know where she is
meaning she should have already paid
closer attention to her surroundings and
should have been more on edge anyways
it's amazing to me how her non-observant
nature through this whole journey has
now proved to us that she deserves
whatever hell this sweet girl runs into
later she wakes up and finds herself
trapped in a mysterious chamber and she
begins to have horrifying visions of
bugs overrunning the city and all of a
sudden she has a flashback to her youth
of her and NASA getting into a bloody
fight and she realizes what's going on
suddenly the machine she's in explodes
and Rin manages to turn back time going
back to when she was just stabbed and
she makes this psycho chick get blown to
[ __ ] and somehow she grows out these
lunar moth Wings which are so freaking
pretty look at him and she sees her
friend nasua symbolically give up her
life for rinse all the while as the
entire Matrix blows up but that's when
Rin finally wakes up for real and
realizes that she's been in a coma
tripping balls since she was a child and
how she got in a coma was from getting
into a fight with her best friend nosua
all those years ago she finally makes
peace for the [ __ ] that her childhood
friend put her through just as she sees
a sea of bugs taking over the city but
what do you guys think about the video
it's a crazy one right let us know what
you like about it and what you didn't
like about it don't forget to like
subscribe leave a comment down below and
as always don't forget to check out our
how to beat playlist